ils étaient des centaines de fidèles à
la grande messe de rentrée pour célébrer
sa réouverture
l'église notre dame de l'espérance a
repris vie ce dimanche à maurepas
c'était un moment d'émotion vraiment
vraiment fort parce que moi j'ai rêvé la
dernière l'église venait de fermer
il a fallu voilà prendre des décisions
pour essayer de faire face à la
conjoncture et la non après fort
commencent tous ensemble et par rossi
aussi a vraiment envie de se retrouver
après un an de travaux et de fermeture
l'édifice religieux avait rouvert ses
portes aux fidèles depuis la mi juillet
il ya beaucoup de gens qui viennent
officiellement de pays
d'ailleurs qui ont pour qui l'église
c'est vraiment faire le bâtiment églises
ses rangs le centre du village c'est
tout le monde se retrouveront ils
passent la journée on joue au foot
dehors en afrique au brésil moi j'étais
au brésil et l'a donc ces populations là
elles sont très heureuses parce que
l'élysée ont été fermés babre gens sont
à pied aller dans les petites églises un
peu loin c'est difficile là on voit
beaucoup de gens venir enfin c'est
grisant le matin mais devant la porte de
lille on va les gens arrivés à pied de
partout à travers la place et on se
retrouve voilà tout l'office a été
célébré avec émotion par monseigneur
stanislas lalanne évêque de pontoise et
ancien curé de la paroisse pour moi
c'est impressionnant parce que j'ai été
écoeurée jusqu'à 2,94 à 99 ça fait
presque vingt ans et puis je retrouve
beaucoup de visages connus et puis on va
faire dans mon ministère de prêtre
ces cinq ans ont été demandés ça a été
magnifique
la communauté vivante elle est ouverte
aux autres la messe a été suivie d'une
kermesse ouvre pas et boissons attendait
les fidèles pour cette journée riche en
nouveautés les paroissiens ont également
fêté leurs nouveaux saints patrons notre
dame de l'espérance